my name is Jeremy bullet i am the
director producer writer one of the
writers on mobsters it's pretty much a
webseries it's it's a good fellow suites
curb your enthusiasm Jamie moved here
from New York about 10 years ago in 10
years and between 13 and he said why is
avocado in everything and why do they
toast their sobs and you know what's
going on with these v-neck shirts and he
thought to himself what if guys from
Goodfellas and casinos were in LA
present time they'd be killing everybody
and he pretty much came up with a great
show that's what the shows about mix it
with us and we have the ultimate dream
team right here it's better than those
guys over there in London right now I
mean you know we got lucky I mean we've
known each other for years we've got
great chemistry and it really shows
through each episode
well aside from having do chemistry
though there are times probably where I
got a little tense oh so how do you
what's your rule I don't go to bed angry
why what's your what's your rule when
you can always go to bed with a kiss on
the cheek yeah well my kiss stay mad at
these guys i've known him too long yeah
i didn't get anything itself gets tense
because we're running out of time and
i'll do the clap let's go i think the
main role the one thing that sets our
show apart is we really are very
ambitious with we don't want this to
look like your standard web series I
mean you really try and take it to the
next level so a lot of times when it
does get tight or stressful it's cuz of
your Russian because we have so much we
need to get it if we don't sail in us we
keep going to just keep you we shoot on
average about 10 pages and uh I'd say 16
hours you know I mean like 2 8-hour days
so you know it's a lot to shoot I mean
I'm under shooting that by saying eight
hours that's why these guys yeah yeah if
we all get matter like said I'm just
trying to be mad but yeah we try so hard
we try to make it the next level always
this episode is starring Alan covert
he's the starboard movie called
grandma's boy he's been in every single
out of Sailor movie and our newest
episode is starring julie gonzalo she's
a star of dallas which is a hit show on
TV right now we always try to take it to
that next level
so you guys are walking the red carpet
at Holly shorts 2012 it all looks very
glamorous how much time are you actually
putting in behind the scenes I don't
even know how to much a hundred percent
between the four of us it's we do one
hundred percent of the behind-the-scenes
40 minutes you know we do we do pretty
much every aspect of it and we write it
we produce it we directed edited star in
it you know it's really our project and
we're lucky enough to have people to
work with us and we made it a nice big
production team and you know it really
is our show you know you're gonna say to
another another one of the things about
web series is you know this is really
only on us so our show is only limited
by how much work you're willing to put
into it as we put in a lot so that's why
I like if we don't get stressed on set
if we don't get mad at each other on set
that means we're not pushing hard enough
you know what I mean any meltdowns you
want to talk about no no I mean we all
grew up together we're all friends so
there's a meltdown it's more about like
what you ate my sandwich it's never it's
never anything big like you my
girlfriend didn't hook I got married
he's marielle's wife oh yeah we have
such a good time especially Jer takes
care of it he's one of the best
directors in town we we usually shoot at
my buddy's bar all to my buddy altomare
called the oaks in sherman oaks and we
have a visual effects artist dear i'd
read hills of course every time Santa
we're lucky with us through we're lucky
with our crew they love it as much as we
do so that's what what shows at each
other and lastly are you on YouTube and
it's not why you're not on YouTube
luxury on Murdoch wroth Funny or Die
really want to try to get that
that's something that's really important
to us is you know that caliber of comedy
is really what we're a spiral so that's
what we're going for it's one of you the
social media guru play our part no what
do you mean to be like to get high what
does that mean no no social media which
one of yous with social media I
hate to say it but this guy he's our
grease man he doesn't get embarrassed he
has no humility he'll go up to anybody
guys get Wilson and ask him to be in it
yeah and get Jack Nicholson idiot you
know what's really crazy this guy calls
me one night he says hey I got Henry
Hill you know Henry Hill is to be in
mobster like you're kidding me
he died two weeks later so yeah when I
got the email for fruit yeah but I mean
this guy he's the one who makes our
phone calls and gets us in the front
door yeah she really does
and where can we see the series
funnyordie com or jeremy foley calm or
just google mobsters a link over
popsters Brian Austin Green dalka money